Choosing the right editor can be tricky
due to the overwhelming options and
religious developer battles.
It's almost as bad as the ongoing
battle of taps versus basis, or
semicolon haters and lovers.
I'm making it super easy for you.
In this course,
we'll stick to Sublime text three.
>> So out of all the choices out there,
why are we going with Sublime?
>> Well it's simple.
Sublime is four to five times more
popular than the competition.
It's extendable, fast, and
very well supported by our community.
For free alternatives check
out GitHub's Atom editor.
It builds on a similar
plugin architecture.
It's the new kid on the block, and
it's getting better every day.
In the end, I won't be offended if
you decide to use another editor.
As long as you stay away from Notepad.
Just make sure it's fast enough,
can be extended with functionality, and
is well supported and stable.